i love you
[Music]
sure kourtney kardashian and travis
barker say i love you
but are they headed towards i do a
source tells et
quote courtney and travis are in love
and have talked about their future and
the possibility
of getting engaged and married the
source adds quote
courtney hasn't felt this strong about
anyone in a while
and can see a forever with travis and
while the couple hasn't been official
for very long
they haven't shied away from showing off
their love for each other
hitting up the desert for a pda filled
vacation last month
and documenting some steamy moments from
the trip
on instagram and et source confirms
their chemistry
is off the charts quote although the
couple hasn't been together for a while
they've known each other for years and
have a strong connection
so what does the 42 year old reality
star's famous fam think of her new
relationship
according to our source they are so
here for it quote courtney's family
hasn't seen her this happy in a while
and they love travis the couple's kids
get along great
and that has made things much easier for
them
i love it of course the push founder
shares three children with her ex
scott disick while travis shares two
kiddos with his ex-wife shayna mokler
courtney and travis or should we call
them kravis
started dating in january and have been
full steam ahead ever since
just last month the lovebirds took their
kids on a family ski vacation
and later spent easter golfing with the
kardashian jenner crew
travis even got court's name inked on
his
chest this is insane as for courtney and
scott
a source previously told e.t it's been
an adjustment for him seeing court in a
serious relationship
quote he is still trying to get used to
it scott is still close with courtney
but things between them have changed a
bit
and that changed dynamic has played out
on the current and final season of
keeping up
i feel like it annoys me like when you
flirt with this lifeguard
i'm definitely not flirting with the
lifeguard then it's my insecurity then i
feel like that i just
don't like seeing you with another guy
or a guy it hurt me when you're with
somebody else
of course scott is currently dating 19
year old model amelia hamlin
and no matter what court and scott
continue to
crush it as co-parents something
courtney's sister khloe kardashian
praised them for during a chat with e.t
in 2019.
it's hard work for all parties they're
all really
everybody's invested strong like it's
i'm really proud of all of them
i think everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but
my mom and my dad were like that it took
them years but my dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and would
play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be and
love is love and i'm so proud of them
and i'm so proud of them promoting that
it's a beautiful thing to get along with
each other and for your kids to see that
you